[Musique]
je peux vous poser une question purement
théorique là je n'aime pas ça les
questions théoriques je ne pense pas que
vous aimerez la vraie question non plus
vous vous êtes procuré le rapport
s'étend couvrables c'est une atteinte
gravissime à la sécurité nationale sa
fuite et du pentagone les documents de
guerre les plus hautement
confidentielles time is détient sept
mille pages qui raconte en détail 30 ans
de mensonges de la maison blanche sur la
guerre du vietnam
tous ces mensonges
il faut que c'était pas que soit révolu
ok tout le monde s'inquiète de voir une
femme à la tête du journal
ils craignent que vous n'ayez pas le
cran de prendre les décisions difficiles
partir je vous remercie pour votre
franchise allons faire notre boulot
dégoter moi ce document on parle de
divulguer des secrets que le
gouvernement garde depuis des années
c'est légal ça qu'est ce que tu crois
qu'on fait ici comme métier mon droit
ben j'ai peut-être quelque chose
ça doit être précieuse que vous devez
rien ce sont des documents secret
défense
le new york times sur l'interdiction de
continuer à publier des documents
confidentiels concernant la guerre du
vietnam
si on publie on comparaît devant la cour
suprême la semaine prochaine c'est à
dire
nous pourrions tous finir en prison
d'avoir pris une telle décision
d'avoir risqué sa fortune et
l'entreprise à laquelle elle a consacré
sa vie
ça je trouve ça vraiment courageux
si le gouvernement l'emportent le
washington post cessera d'exister
si nous on leur demande pas des comptes
qui le fera
pourront demander des comptes à personne
c'est notre journal de paris m
seul mobilisera toute la puissance de la
présidence et s'il existe un moyen de
détruire
tu peux être certaine qu'il le trouvera
tu te demande un conseil bob pas ta
permission
on ne peut pas faire ça l'héritage
spirituel du journal est en jeu
se passera-t-il à six bonnes publiées
on sera perdant le pays qui sera perdant
qu'est ce que vous comptez faire madame
g